the countdown is on until super bowl 56
on february 13th where the la rams will
take on the cincinnati bengals from
their home stadium in l.a
yes but roz we're also very excited for
the halftime show we got dr dre in l.a
which is going to be epic and also
mickey guyton's performance on the star
spangled banner which of course is a
huge honor for any recording artist not
to mention one of the most
nerve-wracking performances to do
uh yeah faith hill can relate to this as
she stopped by the late show with
stephen colbert
and recalled the terrifying experience
singing the anthem at the super bowl in
2000 but nothing tops that time she
forgot the lyrics just minutes before a
tennessee tights playoff game
you sang the super bowl in 2000
what is that like to sing the national
anthem at the super bowl what did the
pressure must be extraordinary
the most extraordinary amount of
pressure ever afraid you would like
forget the lyrics or something like that
i have forgotten the lyrics wow i have
and and it's one of those songs that you
know so well and you think i'll never
forget the lyrics this happened to me
before
uh it was at a playoff game
many years prior i was at the dallas i
was singing at a dallas playoff game at
the beginning of my career
and i'm walking i was asked to sing the
national anthem playoff game and i'm
walking out to the center of the field
with this
uh very generous uh guard this woman
that was walking me out and i say to her
and this is televised
would you happen to know the just the
first word of the national anthem
all i need is the first word the oh
and uh
and she said
seriously and i said and we're walking
like hand in hand i said i'm serious
i'm very serious
she said oh my honey i don't know
and i said oh i said that's not what you
want i don't know i don't know i don't
know either okay i'm just gonna sing
amazing grace because they'll forgive me
for that
so i literally honest to god i failed on
the national level i did not i did not
but i honest to god i was going like if
i did when i hit that center and the and
it went live
if i didn't have oh say
it was gonna be amazing grace